ينضم الينا من عمان الان لواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك حضره اللواء
عند الحديث الان عن امكانيه صدام مباشر
بين روسيا واشنطن هل هذا وارد عسكريا
حتى هذه اللحظه لا حتى هذه اللحظه هناك
التحذيرات من خطر الانزلاق نحو مواجهه
والمواجهه يجب ان نضعها في مستويين هل هو
مواجهه على المستوى الادنى اي على سبيل
المثال اختراق طائره لاجواء دوله من دول
النيته سقوط صاروخ في همم في دوله من دول
النيته توجيه ضربه لشاحنه اسلحه ام نرتقي
الى المستوى الاعلى وهو على الصراع النووي
ودخول الثالوث الاستراتيجي على الخط السقف
الاعلى
امر مقطوع به انه يصعب جدا او ينظر جدا ان
يحدث اما حدوث خطا في المستوى الادنى قد
يحدث وقبل تقريبا اكثر من شهر عندما سقط
صاروخ داخل بولندا وتحدثنا ورشحنا ان يكون
صاروخ 300 سقط بالخطا وهذا ما سب الان رغم
التصعيد في الخطاب السياسي والعسكري لكن
هناك قنوات اتصال وهناك خط ساخن يجب ان
يبقى موجود وقائعم لماذا لانه لا يمكن
الوصول الى نتيجه ايجابيه من حدود في هذا
الصراع وبالتالي ستكون النتيجه خاسر خاسر
لا يوجد رابح في هذا الصراع حتى وان
ارتفعت نبره التصريحات من هذا الجانب او
من ذلك على فكره
هذه التصريحات تصريحات بوتين بدات مستهينه
بنظام الفريق وكانت بانها ليست على كفاءه
كبيره وهي اقل من اس 300
تقنيا هل هذا الكلام دقيق
لا يعني اقول ان باتريوت باك 3 اتحدث عن
باتريوت النسخه المحدثه باك 3 اكثر تطورا
وفاعليه من صواريخ اس 300 حسب المعلومات
التي اطلعنا عليها واجرينا مقارنه ما بين
تلك المنظومتين ولكن هي اقل كفاءه من اس
400 لماذا لان اس 4
تصميمه مختلف هنا همم 16 صاروخ على المنصه
تلك يوجد فيها كذلك 16 صاروخ لكن الصواريخ
هناك اربعه مدايات عندما اقول اربعه
صواريخ في الاس 400 اتحدث عن مسافه 400
كيلو متر 250 كيلو متر 150 كيلو متر الى
غير ذلك اذا بيننا هنا اتحدث عن منظومه
متماثله الصواريخ ال 16 صاروخ هي نفس
المواصفات نفس المدنيه الميداليات ونفس
التقنيات اذا هي تقع في نقطه بين اس 3 واس
400 ولكن قطعا هي اكثر كفاءه من اس 300
واعتقد ولا ولا احمل الكلمات ان الرئيس
بوتين كان يقصد اس 400 شكرا جزيلا لك اللي
هو فايز الدويري من عمان